if I didn't have the support that I had  in terms of them you know grandparents  around  um I don't know how I would work just  generally speaking so I don't know how  people without grandparents and parents  kind of support them go back into the  workplace and what are your specific  demands what do you want to see change  we'd like to not not be made to feel bad  for wanting to work I want to and the  only way that that can happen is if  flexible working is something that is  offered to everyone  and I think as well you know Child Care  is is a really  um it's a massive factor in deciding  whether or not you can have a career as  a woman as a mother and if you know  we're 50 of the workforce and we really  should be like you know made it should  be made a priority by now